[Music]
the mobility of people within the
European Union has increased massively
in recent years consequently it has
become essential to ensure efficient
cross-border healthcare for all citizens
the European health data space will play
a major role by facilitating the
exchange of health information across
borders in a secure and integrated way
two cross-border infrastructures are at
the heart of the European health data
space my health at EU and Health Data at
EU in Brussels we met with an e-health
expert in order to understand their
impact for health systems and patients
my helper to you
enables health professionals to access
to essential information for example
pharmacists will need to access
prescription issued in another country
doctors in a hospital will need to have
access to essential information like
allergies vaccination records past
illness or current medication
medical records are translated into the
healthcare professionals language this
allows any European citizen traveling
through the European Union to receive
care as if it were in their own country
under my health rtu the access to health
data is possible through the national
contact points NCP which will be
gradually set up in all member states
and the European coordination services
that harmonize data exchange between
nations
Health Data at EU facilitates access to
electronic health information for
secondary use such as research
Innovation or policy making this offers
the opportunity to take advantage of a
huge catalog of Health Data researchers
institutions or companies will need to
require a permit from a Health Data
access body to be set up in all member
states there is no centralized European
database with all data from patients
data stays where it was collected and is
accessed when it's needed
my health at EU services such as
e-prescriptions and patient summary are
already available in 10 European
countries in the coming years both
services will be gradually implemented
across the European Union
a pilot version of Health Data EU is
going to be set up over the next two
years to test on a small scale the
challenges surrounding Access to Health
Data
the paris-based Health Data Hub leads
the Consortium that will operate the
pilot project
this French public agency specializes in
health data management
no employee if the Health Data Hub has
access to data that's directly
identifiable that's a rule of the Hub
the data is encrypted the encryption
keys and the whole encryption system is
something that's entirely owned by The
Hub we have an extremely high level of
security That's essential for data like
this
Finland is another member of that
Consortium fin data brings a deep
experience about guidance and protection
on the secondary use of Health Data in
the context of public interest projects
he never give out a so-called direct
identifiers so name social security
number variables that directly identify
people the data is always pseudonymized
what means removing the identificating
information or it can be even anonymized
which means that it's in a form that
person can't be identified in such an
outstanding technological ecosystem
security and data protection will play a
crucial role in gaining the trust of all
citizens
foreign
[Music]